we are thrilled to have back here on the
show one of the biggest football fans
that I know one of the best musicians
that I know and his new album with Alice
in Chains it's called Renier fog and it
will be available one week from this
Friday the 9th annual Alice in Chains
Fantasy Football League and charity
auction will be going down on Thursday
August 30th broadcast live on Sirius XM
I will be back in that league for a
third straight year pleased to be with
Jerry Cantrell great to see you brother
thanks for having are you doing always
good to be here okay always glad to have
you I mean you got a pretty good record
you got a Super Bowl appearance and a
championship last year 10 championship
around a championship run I didn't make
the championship with loss in the final
because you have Fabiano in it in fact I
was in like 19 leagues because yeah is
this for a living it kind of sucks
having him in the league but you know my
crazy good yeah he's so good he's a good
soul good person yeah but he should be
out yeah we got a little revenge because
we Mike and I play it in his League last
year as well yes and Inez took his
league so oh I know his league he took
our league so his little tit-for-tat so
you eat he grabbed a little piece of
Alice and changed forever and then you
grab some grab tell me about this new
album available in a couple of Fridays
it's in a really good record we spent we
spent all the last year making it and we
recorded the basic tracks in Seattle we
kind of we kind of went home you know we
went we went to studio X which used to
be bad animals which was owned by heart
and we recorded our third studio record
there so of this era actually we
recorded our third studio record in that
same studio so it kind of worked out we
had there's a great song on the record
called Rainier fog and maybe one of the
maybe one of the next singles we have a
new single out right now called never
fade and we had a good run with the one
you know but uh I don't know we felt
like we wanted to go home and it was
great to spend the summer there and you
know soak up some of that energy and and
kind of celebrate celebrate where we
come from our history and and make make
some new music moving for
yeah yeah and and so when you when you
think of Randy Rainier fog I mean
obviously that is yeah Pacific Northwest
is you can pause now right there man
it's I mean you can't it dominates the
skyline so as it flies it's kind of like
the beacon and we grew up in the shadow
of that thing and and you know it's kind
of rainy and foggy up there and it's
kind of a reference to I guess it's kind
of a reference to the obscurity that we
all came out of and and you know we kind
of all rose out of the fog in the Great
Northwest and I mean you're about that
and you're about to go back on the road
and the Mariners announced an Allison
change not it's safe now to help kick
this whole I need somebody to play catch
with me because I got a I got to throw
out the first pitch so I got to make
sure to do that right well I think all
four of us are and that means they'll
probably be four balls in the dirt so is
I want to be the one that goes into the
gloves I thought it would just be you on
the bump right there yeah well I think
that was kind of the vibe but I think
the I saw an email last night and it
seems like the vote is all four of us
want to do it so okay so now just one
one thing to do is again certainly if
you're gonna be sitting there you know
feeling nervous it'll be easy for you to
remember this throw up throw up when I'm
I don't mean actually vomit yeah yeah
throw up because first time I did the
first time I did it I almost probably
before well I did it with Randy Johnson
back in the day hey man I'll take tips
any day from you man and Randy Johnson
or any Randy Johnson was the catcher I
want I walked out and speaking of throw
up just back in the old days and I might
have had a few and I don't think I went
to sleep that night and I showed up in a
flannel shirt and some flip-flops and I
went out to the no I went out to the
mound and actually threw if it wasn't a
strike it was just outside it was
actually pretty good and Randy Johnson
was my that was my catcher yeah like you
should have to do it so this is the
second time but obviously this is in
promotion of the album Renier fog that's
gonna be available on the 24th of August
and then your your tour
in Vancouver on the 22nd yalla by the
White River amphitheatre in beautiful
Seattle that's right yeah this is our
third leg we've already been out on the
road we did a we did a run through the
East Coast about three months ago we
just had a great run through through
Europe and ended in Tel Aviv which we
had never played so we spent about six
weeks over in Europe and I've just had
about two or three weeks off and it's
time to go back to Kay ready to roll
Alison change Jerry Cantrell here on the
Rich Eisen show you know it's amazing to
me that I'm saying this it's true every
year there's a handful of teams that you
have no idea how they're gonna look in
the NFL
yeah like this year okay I'll give you a
couple the Colts yeah who knows what
Andrew Luck's gonna do to be a bit
difference-maker or not no earthly idea
yeah the Bears could be great maybe not
Chargers no idea chargers charters can
be good could be really good I I'm a I'm
an expecting to be good though
okay and the same thing in a way could
be said about your your Seahawks yeah no
earthly idea I got no clue either I mean
we're in the dreaded rebuild phase so or
are you I don't know I'm a you know
that's a really good point I was
thinking about that on the way over here
and there's there's there's good talent
there and we've got a great quarterback
so that's that's that's that's a huge
that's a huge thing also we have a great
coach a great owner and a great GM so
the the you know I mean the the the
support is there and the team is there
so who knows you know we could be I
don't think any less but it this way I
don't think anybody's expecting us to do
much but we could do some damage
I agree nobody's expecting Seattle to do
much yeah at all yeah that in a way the
Cardinals are also another one of those
teams you have no idea yet they're going
to look like that they could be yeah in
the playoff hunt or not
well they got David David Johnson back
there feeling that is for sure but is
Sam Brad for the guy if Josh Rosen is
the guy can he be yeah and can get them
to the playoffs this first year I think
you probably see him at some point this
year I think you might see him week one
yeah actually yeah I think he records a
good quarterback but I'll stay healthy I
know I and and and to me if you've got a
young guy go with him right now and
certainly if they're competing well
look I mean your team is the perfect
example with with Russell Wilson's right
let's not right let's not forget the
amount of money that we spent on on a
Flynn right yeah
Flynn to be brought in they had Tavares
Jackson and let's get ready got in the
third round and see what's going on
right that's right and that worked out
pretty well I mean there's a really good
crop of young quarterbacks and it'll be
interesting to see what the teams do
with them who's the guy in Cleveland
Baker Mayfield yeah I know we're just
talking about to Rod Taylor being the
guy now that's got he's gonna be yeah I
mean this is the bad organization I mean
I don't know somebody's got to wrangle
that thing it's it's run badly or or
they have a playmakers all over the law
you know no they do they do that but I
mean like there's always that there's
always that question do you do do do you
Aaron Rodgers the guy do do you sit him
behind a good quarterback and let him
learn the thing or do you throw them out
there and you're like Troy Aikman style
you kind of like what do you do
I thought you throw him out there yeah
Jerry came in that way to find out Jerry
Cantrell ivalice and changed here on the
Rich Eisen show let's take a break come
back and just de dive headfirst into
fantasy for talk about the league and I
have somebody to to join the league
that's awesome okay yeah we need to I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna forward an
individual to join the league and then
also break the news to you about my
availability to be at the draft already
kind of knew about that all right Jerry
Cantrell of Allison changes here also in
the middle of this hour Dabo Swinney of
Clemson football will be calling into
the show that's all coming up here on
the Rich Eisen show you GM is doing fine
for you hi doc good
[Music]
all right welcome back to the show Dabo
Swinney of Clemson football be calling
in to the show in about 14 minutes so a
nice chunk of time to sit here and talk
a little bit of fantasy football with
the I would are you the Commissioner of
this league Jerry can I'm not your
Commissioner are one of our management
team Mark Wakefield has done a great
know he sends the emails and whatever so
you're the figurehead would you say yes
so it was supposed to be you know Mike
it was something that Mike and I decided
to start together but it seems like I do
- yeah I do all the work so okay fantasy
football league and charity auction
every year you broadcast the draft live
from your home on Sirius XM you choose
last year the Tuesday before the season
when I'm on NFL Network all the time
so I couldn't make it and then the other
times last this year and the year before
my daughter's birthday that's right yeah
that was a legitimate excuse it is it
still is again I can't look a
five-year-old in the face and say sorry
sweetheart I gotta go hang out with it's
a trump card and and Jerry Cantrell's
living room with the Jackalope on the
wall you know make sure that I'm there
to draft what Antonio Callaway and round
10
you know sorry sweetheart so understand
Chris Brockman will be there of course
is solid we have chosen our team name
had you know what your team name is good
as always the aroma of Tacoma aroma of
ICA Roma and Tacoma right now hey I see
so it's a oh okay a ot okay I see that's
right and then ours this year after much
deliberation as a matter of fact we
chose it from we we put a bracket
together of all the phrases that I've
dropped or we've all dropped here on the
show throughout the last few months and
then had Paul Rudd who is a die-hard
fantasy player okay choose the name and
our name of is touch of the Vermeil
because whenever somebody that's misty
or starts crying you get a touch of the
just a little touch of the Vermeil
that's solid I back it yeah and some of
the other names that were deep logins
almost made it
penny log because you know when you talk
about Kenny Loggins music premature horn
I mean premature morning rush one dolmen
wormhole was another but a touch of the
Vermeil one there you go I think you
went with the right one okay there we go
and we got a whole host of a choice of
that great avatar Oh who is in this
league that folks can follow along on
our channel we're still filling it up
we've got we've got the regulars you
know we got me Mike
we got Duff McKagan from Guns'n'Roses we
got Scotty in we got yourself
I love with a regular Fabiano yeah we
got Fabiano I think we got the Bella
Twins coming in this year okay we I
think Jerry O'Connell is gonna do it
okay you mentioned somebody that might
be yes a friend of the program and a
friend who is a loves fantasy sports
Jeff Garlin come on man yeah he wants me
to give you his phone number and no
problem yeah you're welcome oh come on
in Jeff Garlin yeah by the way he I
think he's gonna come to the draft and
he will I hope so I hope so we once did
a draft celebrity League on the NFL
Network years ago and we had Jaleel
White one of the actors from family
matters okay who didn't really want to
be called Errol and garland called him
herckel and exclusively for the
three-hour draft okay even named a
subsequent fantasy league that he was
the Commissioner of the oral aural early
oh my god so be careful is what I'm
saying about your inviting into your
house literally and figuratively okay
okay so yeah all right so Garland and
then you're are you looking for one more
or what yeah we're looking for we're
looking for a few more we we we lost a
member last year a good friend Vinnie
Paul had passed away right and so he was
a charter member and and a champion as
well and we're gonna we're gonna invite
somebody in and we're also gonna change
the NFL has the Vince Lombardi they're
gonna have the Vinnie Paul it's gonna be
our trophy no kidding yeah so what does
the trophy gonna look like we're we've
got two mock-ups one is one is his drum
set and the other is actually like a
like a Hall of Fame bust I think I think
the bust so what you're saying is
by Christmas time this year the Vinnie
Paul will be on that shelf yeah or I
could bring it by and show it to you
here's what must happen okay you know
two years ago you and I were in yeah
proposed a big deal okay you came here a
week before and started trash-talking
okay and we made a bet we did that I
lost yep because I appeared on this show
for all three hours in the kit crust it
crushed it of obviously showing it right
here on this Lexie Lexie Fox yep of
Steel Panther yeah and you've you
outfitted me you personally came in to
make sure that I I looked like they may
or may not know something about dressing
like that about campus here I went in
order to coffee across the thoroughfare
here that was that capper the shades and
then by the way I wound up I wound up
performing with Steel Panther Pappas was
shaking his head I heard I did yeah
performing so I may actually haven't
been at that that's right all it was a
loss win okay yeah we were gonna try and
run it back next last year right but we
did not get in we both knocked out in
the championship correct yeah so I
wanted this year right now is we're
sitting here weeks before the draft
Allison changed fantasy football league
and charity auction by the way and two
organizations big league impact and
music for relief will be benefited by
whatever is put out there on auction
we've got to come up with a wager all
right whoever finishes better okay not
regular season overall
alright I got that so if you make the
playoffs and I don't un if I make it ups
and you don't I win and then whoever
lasts longer in the playoffs and then
what it would be a tie-break most points
noise a lots if we go out in the same
round most points yeah so you and I will
definitely have alright if you have
something in mind alright
- I'm gonna dumb the free world wants to
see this happen
what what I'm about to say do you want
to run back the same thing do you have
something in mind as well for me or what
I'm just throwing this on you live on
our yeah I know where I dress the same
way for another three-hour live TV I
wish my brain was a bit sharper but I
might need to think about for a sec yeah
I will still run back the same do you
remember what you were gonna do you're
gonna have me come on here and do the
singer sing let it go from frozen
acoustic yeah
Cantrell of Alice in Chains we'll have
to come here and sing every last damn
lyric do you have a second choice you
know that was a bet then it was for all
the marbles this is just for record let
it go is a timeless snow I know that I
know you really want me to do that
frozen one of these two things is going
to happen that or whatever you cook up
for me that has to be similar okay okay
I posed we table this for a later day we
put a pin in it just but not too long
not too long this is just give me it
just give me a minute to think about who
got this but we need some it's got to be
you're coming on the podcast I do with
my wife later you get a second shot okay
and so when do we find out our draft
position uh that should be coming up
here pretty quick I'll talk to mark
today and got emails I want to know yeah
we've never had that one the the one
hole yeah I don't like one I'd rather be
in the middle somewhere really I'd
rather be in that four five six range
fours yeah four it's not PPR right it's
no no we did make some changes we're
going full point PPR this year so it was
a half a point right yeah and we are
also adding two members and now it's a
12 team league so I noticed I don't hear
the name Maurice jones-drew is he not
invited back uh we his name wasn't up
for consideration I mean he didn't even
say he wanted to be in the league I mean
we've I've been in a few leagues with
MGMT and I love MJ but but but but you
know
if his team does assert isn't doing that
well he stops stop setting lineups kinda
gives easy wins than guys that's not
cool man let me question in turn what's
worse
that's what's worse fantasy somebody who
doesn't set their lineup because they
lose interest because their team isn't
doing okay or somebody who never
responds to a trade request because both
are flagrant violations
okay spirit of fantasy I feel for the
lineup because it gives it upsets the
balance the competitive balance right it
gives somebody an easy win that [ __ ] in
one or or whatever it just it makes the
play unfair but what if you're the
beneficiary of the win yeah I I guess so
but it still sucks because because I've
been in the I've been in the situation
where I'm the guy like that's not not
getting the easy win and I've also been
on the guy getting the easy when it
still sucks it's not cool to everybody
else in the league so mjd Maurice Jones
you know is a palco lineup setter he's a
pal I've seen him I've seen him miss
some lineup so it's all I'm saying Jerry
Cantrell of Allison's new album Rainier
fob yeah and I'm promoting your album
just to set you up for about to cut you
down sir okay you also have a a pet
peeve it's a pet peeve of mine
okay fantasy that know you and you know
where I'm going I do you are one of
those whiner complainer textures oh yeah
during the competition I'm playing you I
am it's a voodoo wine or win
congratulations
[Music]
I've got five more players to come you
know owner Jerry you know what it takes
one to know one cuz I've got I've gotten
a few I've got a few from you too as
well
because I know you're gonna do it to me
I am hey man it takes one to know one
I know you are too that's why I can
throw him at you man cuz you throw him
right back I love the reverse jinx wine
absolutely guilty as charged guilty as
charged
alright so aroma in Tacoma of Tacoma
aroma of Tacoma yeah okay yeah does not
survive longer than me yeah you must
sing let it go from frozen acoustic
right let's talk about it let's talk
about it if we're do I tell you what you
have to do it no that's that's that's
that's a that's a Super Bowl that's a
Super Bowl level waiter
no you I think I think best record is a
little bit down there that's a
performance man you know come on hey
that's a performance man I take that I
take that seriously man that's I tell
you what if we make it to the Super Bowl
again okay if we make it to the Super
Bowl again it could happen probably we
had a deal and now you're not on hold I
gotta go you know you were trying to
make a deal I will make a deal with you
let's let's figure it out by today but I
think a live performance is a Super Bowl
level bet I think best record is
something else yeah Allisyn change comm
check out Rainier fog
good to see you Jerry good to see you
too man thank for having Jerry Cantrell
of Allison change here the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience